welcome to the show friends and
neighbors and countrymen I hope you
enjoyed the Super Bowl last night it's
always very traumatizing to watch the
Super Bowl maybe you can relate but
after your team gets eliminated from the
playoffs and the Super Bowl is on and
everybody's happy and all they're all
the fans of those two teams are very
happy it's it's like if I imagine it's
like going to a wedding right after your
wife left you that's what it's what it
felt like to me only probably worse in
many ways I imagine the good thing
though is that fortunately we did have
the good sense to send our kids to bed
before the halftime show last night
because it's the Super Bowl on network
television starts at 7:00 p.m. on a
Sunday why should anyone think that
would be a family event that's crazy
right why would you ever imagine that
you could sit down with your family with
your kids and watch a football game oh
that's that's unreasonable right it's
unreasonable to expect that that you
should be able to watch the game with
your kids that's what I'm told that's
what I've been told anyway these are the
over the past last night and this
morning is this is what I'm assured that
no note that the idea that I should be
able to watch the game with my kids
that's totally unreasonable I shouldn't
I shouldn't expect that so the halftime
show which seemed to arrive to us via
time portal from 2003 featured JLo and
Shakira singing their hits from or
lip-synching anyway their hits from 17
years ago I was kind of waiting for
maybe Smash Mouth to come on stage or
matchbox 20 or the Goo Goo Dolls
I would have preferred any of those
three actually even Smash Mouth may be
ja Rule or DMX but the fact that it was
dated was was not really the point and
by the way I am gonna tune in I'm
looking forward to you know watching TRL
today to see what Carson Daly thought of
it but that's not really the point and
the fact that no actual football fan
listens to Jennifer Lopez or Shakira is
not the point either because this is
something that now I've been I've been
suggesting for years that maybe the NFL
might want to think about possibly
having a halftime show featuring acts
former's that football fans are actually
interested in just an idea thrown it out
there but that's that's not the point
either the point is that JLo in
particular decided that this nationally
televised broadcast on network TV was a
good forum to do things like shove her
crotch directly in the camera then dance
around on a stripper pole of course she
was barely clothed there was plenty of
twerking and so on it was it was the
kind of performance that would make a
lot of sense in a strip club
or even at a Jennifer Lopez concert for
whoever would want to go to something
like that because it's something that
you would pay to attend and you go into
it knowing that she's a 50 year old
woman desperate for attention and
lacking the artistic skill to get that
attention by making actually good music
that's one thing I thought about during
the show by the way that this woman is
50 and there there were there were
plenty of people bringing that up oh
she's 50 bringing it up in a in a
positive light like they were impressed
she's 50 and she's still doing this but
I was thinking more she's 50 and she's
still doing this she's been in the music
industry what for like 25 years hasn't
grown at all as an artist that's one
thing you can't accuse jennifer lopez of
apparently do not accuse her of growing
as an artist because she hasn't hocked
at all not even a little bit i remember
back in the late 90s early 2000s she
would always get attention and publicity
she would get herself into the head
headline in the headlines by doing
things like showing up to the VMAs
without any clothes on that sort of
thing and that was back again in the
late 90s early 2000s and here she is 20
years later doing the same stuff as
she's old enough to be an AARP member
she's old enough to be a grandmother
doing the same stuff so she's like
Madonna in that way only Madonna is 93
and still gyrating on stage while
screaming look at me everybody please
look at me and then there's the six
creepy dudes in the audience that are
looking now
I I have a couple of points I wanted to
make about all this but before we do
that a quick word from Ashford
University you know everyone has that
that that dream job that job that maybe
seems out of reach but that you know
you're meant to do you know it's your
vocation your calling some of us are
lucky enough to already be in that job
some of us are still striving for it
well if you're striving it's very
important that you be prepared and what
a lot of people discover is that they
need at least a bachelor's degree to
make that dream of reality but the way
the traditional university system is set
up it's just not feasible or affordable
we talk about this all the time on the
show it's it's not something that a lot
of people are able to do affordably
especially if you're working a job if
you're an adult you have a maybe a
family if kids you've you've got already
got a job well going to some four-year
institution going into physical
classrooms and taking on the whole
workload that might not be you might not
be able to do that logistically that's
where Ashford University comes in
Ashford University's online bachelor's
and master's degree programs allow you
to learn at your own pace you can study
whatever your the most comfortable
learning whenever you the most
comfortable learning one course at a
time means that Ashford University's
six-week long courses allow you to take
just one course at a time so again
that's that that's a work that
manageable workload being enrolled in
one class at Ashford means that you're
still considered a full-time student and
here's a good thing no standardized
tests are required so the SAT the GRE
the GMAT other standardized test scores
are not required for enrolling at
Ashford University I could tell you for
me personally sitting in a classroom
doesn't work it's never never has that's
why the flexibility of being able to
study wherever you want being able to
take one class at a time it's all about
you know having a manageable workload
again because you've got plenty of other
things going on in your life so get on
the road till are earning your degree
and making your dream job of reality and
enroll now by going to Ashford dot edu
slash Walsh again that's Ashford dot edu
slash Walsh Ashford dot edu slash Walsh
I'll spell it out for you a sh F Ord edu
slash Walsh and start getting your
degree today
all right back to the halftime show
here's my point about theirs here's my
radical position I think football games
should be family events they should be
appropriate for everybody that's what
the Superbowl should be I should be able
to watch it with my kids now because I'm
not naive I know that I can so that's
why I did send on to bed but it's not
like I'm upset that I can't watch
HBO's nighttime lineup with my kids okay
I'm not turning on premium channels at
ten o'clock at night and saying that
that stuff should be appropriate for my
kids I know that it's not going to be
and that's a if there's inappropriate
stuff for kids that's a good place to
put an HBO at ten o'clock all right we
all get it right but a football game is
Super Bowl airing on network television
at seven o'clock should be appropriate
of course the problem is we live in an
aggressively stupid culture a a stupid
self-absorbed sex obsessed culture where
even the incredibly reasonable point
that I'm making right here the very mild
request that that first Super Bowl
halftime show that doesn't feature
stripper poles
even this is viewed as Puritan extremism
I was someone told me last night and I
was what I was saying this on Twitter
someone said whoa so what you want to
move to a Muslim country where women
have to be covered 24/7 yes because
that's the other option right those are
the only two options either
we've got stripper poles on network TV
at 7:00 o'clock at night during a family
event
either that or women have to be covered
head to toe 24/7 upon penalty of death
there is no room in between it's it's
one or the other right and so those of
us who made this point last night were
greeted with a flood of responses from
people who felt personally attacked that
we were advocating for a minimal level
of decency and respect for children how
about that look just put that way this
is this is not about my own feelings or
anything like that or my tastes or
preferences how about just respect for
children a little bit that that's all
I'm asking of society it's a little
respect they are people they exist there
in society too and we're constantly
worried about how images ideas words
thoughts etc will hurt various groups of
people this is a constant topic of
conversation in our culture today in
fact even in regards to this game there
was there was much discussion about the
Chiefs logo and how the the Chiefs a
team name and mascot and how that might
be hurtful to Native American adults who
are watching so if that's a concern if
we're concerned that say a 40 year old
Native American man may somehow be
traumatized because of the Kansas City
Chiefs if that's a concern that we have
to take into account and talk about then
what about kids who actually are
impressionable and do have an our
fragile in a way understandably they had
an excuse to be their kids did nobody
involved in the halftime show whether
JLo herself or people at NFL people at
the network
think it was on Fox did nobody stop for
a second and go hey cheap kids are gonna
watch this
did anyone do that no they didn't do
that because they don't care nobody
cares about kids nobody's concerned
about protecting them we protect the
feelings of overly sensitive adults but
kids you know who cares nowadays it's
not just it's not just that we aren't
concerned about the content children
might see it's that the very idea that
we should be concerned maybe is insane
to people people see that as insane the
the very very notion the suggestion that
possibly some of this stuff might not be
appropriate for kids and so maybe we
should tone it down a little bit it's
it's it's not even oh I disagree it's oh
my goodness you're you're a lunatic for
even saying that people recoil at the
mere suggestion that maybe just maybe
events like the Super Bowl should be
appropriate for families it's but it's
not a radical suggestion
look there have always been people who
push the boundaries there have always
been there's always been a push
especially on TV towards overly sexual
entertainment and so forth but they're
also used to be a strong push back from
the other direction saying hey let's
keep these things in check a little bit
there are families watching this stuff
so let's keep that in mind
and now there's almost no push back and
what little there is the few who do push
back are screamed at with an insane fury
and an deranged anger you're sexist
you're a racist there were actually
people saying that there are actually P
is the price you I'm saying it as if
you'll be surprised but that yes there
are there are people saying that it's
it's not only sexist but racist if
you're criticizing the halftime show
you're a racist
it's argue that it's racist to object to
strip teases at halftime because the
women are from Latin America and so it's
it's racist to be to criticize that
this is the argument and sexist -
because you see women flashing their
crotches on camera are being empowered
this is very empowering here's a thought
if you think this stuff is empowering go
online and check out who's defending it
because I've gone back and forth with
these people many times over many
different subjects and you see who are
the people valiantly defending a woman's
right to dance on a stripper pole in
front of children well you've got much
brain feminists of course you have
stupid feminists but but who else you've
got them and creepy old men so this is
once again a coalition of stupid
feminists and creepy old men defending
this kind of thing at any time we're
talking about any kind of degeneracy of
this type
the Coalition is always creepy old men
and feminism why do you think those
creepy old men and this is a question to
the most brain feminists why why do you
think the creepy old men are defending
your right here defending your rights to
you no strip in front of kids what do
you get it do you think they're worried
about self-expression and free speech
you think that's what it is
do I need to spell it out it's just like
the men the men who are your allies
they're your allies because they are
very outspoken about their belief in
your right to get an abortion it's a
very pro-choice men why do you why do
you think they're so pro-choice
I need to do I need to get into detail
about it can you not put the pieces
together well if I need to I'll explain
it's because because because they want
to use you as a sexual object and they
don't want to have to worry about a kid
resulting from it and so that's why
they're perfectly happy to use you
discard you and then have you discard
the baby
because these are bad men these are bad
lazy worthless men who are only
concerned about themselves that's the
only thing they care about
and they see you as an object to be used
you are to them nothing more than a
masturbatory aid essentially
you're like a sex toy Seb so much so
that again in order to be able to use
you and fulfill their sexual desires
they're okay with you killing their own
child they don't care
as long as they get what they want
which is a few minutes of fun few
minutes of fun throw you out throw the
kid out they don't care so these are bad
men and they're on your side because
they're against you not because they're
for you and they're also perfectly happy
to see women embarrassing humiliating
disgracing themselves on national TV
because they enjoy seeing it it's
something they enjoy because again these
are losers and and you know there's it's
not like they have meaningful
relationships of women so you know
they're they rely on things like raunchy
halftime shows
so you know that's
that should concern you if you're a
feminist that these are the people on
your side just to I mean just something
to think about
all right now I should mention there was
one good performance last night
Demi Lovato I thought absolutely nailed
the national anthem which is not easy to
sing and I mean not that I know I you
know I I hold a note about as well as
what spaghetti strainer holds water I
guess but it does from what I could tell
it seems like it so it's a really
difficult song is saying which is why
it's taken down so many people who have
attempted it publicly but I thought she
did a beautiful job singing the song and
what what made her I tell you what made
her rendition this is it this is a good
learning opportunity for any other
singer who might attempt to the future
and pretty much any national anthem
performance that we remember as being
great like Whitney Houston okay that's
probably the gold standard what made it
great is well yeah they're very good
singers but they're they're just singing
the song they're not worried about
showing off their vocal range even
though they have beautiful vocal range
and that's gonna come out naturally in
the song but that's not the point
they're not show but they're not trying
to mix it up and make doing it do
anything different with it it's just a
true it's a it's an old traditional song
obviously and that's how they're singing
it and it's beautiful so I thought that
was great but jay-z and beyonce were at
the game and they didn't seem very
impressed by the performance watch
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes they're sitting during the anthem
and and that's really they've been
criticized for this but I think it's
understandable that they would sit
during the anthem because why would you
expect them to stand up and show
gratitude for the country think about
what the country has done to them think
about the persecution and oppression
that they've suffered this this country
has been very unfair to those people who
have been multi millionaire celebrities
almost their entire lives from a very
young age but very unfair they've been
oppressed
I don't know how they've been oppressed
I can't possibly imagine and whatever
form of oppression they've suffered I
would love I would love me some of that
oppression give me a slice of that
oppression give me the oppression that
that ends with you you know having 500
million dollars in the bank I'll take it
yeah it's kind of like the oppression
that Colin Kaepernick has has gone
through his life that has ended with him
being a multi-millionaire absurdly
wealthy individual so you know but hey
it's it's those of us who are not multi
millionaires maybe we just can't
understand that kind of persecution and
so we should just respect the fact that
they were protesting in this way so good
for them real real heroes very valiant
individuals all right um I want to get
emails but before we do by the way also
wanted to mention tomorrow you know make
sure to watch is it State of the Union
address of course so make sure to watch
backstage and their coverage of the
State of the Union on Daley wire you're
not gonna want to miss that tomorrow
Tuesday okay let's go to emails this is
from Kelly says hi Matt wanted to get
your opinion regarding our current state
of social communication I was listening
to a show you did a while back episode
103 why it's impossible to have fruitful
debates in our culture one of the things
you talk about is people having opinions
that can either be a or B and nothing in
between I really enjoyed this particular
show you did and feel that the points
you make in that episode are really
important considering that things have
only become worse since you did the show
so I wonder what you think of our
current state of society and if you
think there's any hope to get to a point
where people actually accept one another
as equals even if they have differences
of opinion I appreciate everything you
do
well Kelly I'd I don't think our ability
to have a fruit
discussion is necessarily predicated on
accepting one another as equals to be
honest I'm not even sure what that means
I know it's something we say all the
time about equality you know we all have
to accept each other as equals but I
don't I don't know what it means when
you when you dig down into it and ask
yourself what it means to you I think
you'll find that even in your own mind
it's a very fuzzy concept I think it's a
fuzzy concept in all of our minds now I
think we should all be legally equal in
that the law should protect all of us
equally although it doesn't unborn
children are not protected under the law
as one example but it should be that's a
legal concept I just I don't think it
has a lot of bearing though on our
personal interactions with each other on
a day-to-day basis and aside from
equality as a legal concept
not sure what it means because the fact
is you and I are not equal or different
in many ways that doesn't mean that one
of us is better or worse it just means
that we're very different and so to say
that we're equal aside from in the legal
way I'm just not sure what it means or
why we would even say
and it might say that we're equal and
doesn't mean one is better or worse but
we could be better or worse I'm sure
you're probably the better camp it's not
it's not you know I'm not a very high
bar to get over but some people are
better than others there there are there
are certainly people in this world who
are morally you know in terms of
intellect and morality and and all of
these things are better than other
people that's a fact so but we use this
we use this term and I just I think it's
something we need to think about what do
we actually mean rights human rights
would be another example of this word
that we use all the time and I don't
think that any of us know exactly what
we mean when we say it except in a
strictly legal context but we use it in
a way that is far beyond just legal now
if I were to ask you I know none of this
is your point whatsoever so I'm going
off on a tangent but that this is what I
do so you have to expect it I'll get
back to your points like I just want to
make this point if you were to ask the
average person what what are rights what
is a right what are they going to tell
you I think probably the average person
would would stutter and have no answer
at all they be flummoxed might even
though they talk about rights all the
time you could next time you hear
somebody saying I have a right to this
or that stop them and say what is that
what is the right
they'll probably be stumped now if if
this person you're talking to is a
believer is a Christian or or you know
as Jewish they'll they'll probably give
you
they'll probably quote the Declaration
of Independence and they'll say oh
rights are endowed by the creator well
even if that's true it doesn't actually
tell you what rights are it's like if I
said what are lions and you said lions
are live in sub-saharan Africa okay it
tells me where they are but it doesn't
tell me what they are it tells me almost
nothing about lions you haven't narrowed
it down very much so saying they're
endowed by the creator okay well what is
in doubt what do you mean and even the
idea that rights are endowed by the
creator I know that now I'm getting into
real heresy in in in my in America but
I'm not even sure if that's true
exactly it kind of depends on what God
concept were going with here when we say
it so it's gonna depend a lot on what
your religion is now Thomas Jefferson
was a deist so for for a deist to talk
about a god that in dows rights i have
no idea what that means because the dias
concept of God is he got the universe
rolling and is now just sitting back
somewhere in the cosmos not carrying
what happens with humans so the idea
that he gave us rights well maybe but
who knows what that even means now if
we're talking about the judeo-christian
god
well did did that God give us you know
it did did did the the biblical God to
talk about rights in that context does
that make sense
I don't know there really isn't any
mention of human rights in the Bible
it's not something that the biblical
writers seem to be concerned about God
doesn't mention it it does doesn't bring
it doesn't come up in the New Testament
now we are told about respecting people
and especially in the particularly
Christ in the New Testament where we're
told quite a bit about treating people
with dignity but that's not hinged on
any concept of universal human rights
that that concept doesn't come up you
would think if that existed we would
have been mentioned
and if you get out of a religious
context completely then then again I
have no idea what you mean by rights
aside from strictly in a legal way we
say God endowed us with a right to free
speech what do you mean by that because
free speech now that sounds like you can
say whatever you want that's what free
speech is except in the Bible there's a
there are a whole bunch of things that
we're told we're not supposed to say
and then even then and then the
government will give us a bunch of other
things we're not supposed to say that
aren't necessarily mentioned the Bible
like you're not allowed to call in bomb
threats don't you know you can't say
fire in a crowded theater slander or
libel well that is in the Bible but so
free speech so it's it's it's free
speech and doubt by the Creator but
there's still a bunch of things you're
not supposed to say ok so it's not free
you have a right to bear arms well I
believe that but not absolutely
obviously then we would all agree I
don't care who you are
you would all agree there are certain
arms you shouldn't be allowed to bear
like nuclear arms for example even if
that's the only example of something
that you think we shouldn't have a right
to have assuming that you would agree
then you don't believe in tell you you
don't think that's an absolute right if
it's not an absolute right then how is
it a right at all what does it mean to
call it a right you go right down the
list there's really no right you can
name that you actually believe in
absolutely they're obviously going to be
exceptions they're going to be
limitations and so how is it a right
this is so far from anything you asked
me about but now I'm it's something I
think about a lot I think the problem is
when we talk about right so we talk
about equality we are we're reaching for
something there's obviously something
there that we are trying to describe
it's a way of talking about something
but what are we talking about and what I
would suggest and I'm not saying and no
I think we are talking about something
real so I'm not saying this is these are
totally worthless mythological concepts
I am saying that they they miss the
point a little bit and they're kind of
confusing and vague and nobody knows
what these words mean which is why we
haven't stopped arguing about them which
is why if you get a hundred people in a
room you ask them what are are you know
god-given human rights you're gonna get
a hundred different answers nobody knows
I think it's we're trying to talk about
something we I think we need better
language we need more precise language
I'm not sure exactly what that language
would be so I don't have all the answers
I do know that one thing and I've
mentioned this before I think that
oftentimes when we talk about rights it
would get closer to the to the heart of
the
matter and would be more clarifying if
instead of talking about rights we
talked about responsibilities so even
something like the abortion issue we
talked about a right to life well do we
have an absolute right to life no of
course we don't because if you believe
in capital punishment you don't think of
it we have an absolute right to life if
you believe it's in self-defense that
means not an absolute right to life if
you believe that war could be just in
some cases killing enemy combatants not
an absolute right to life and certainly
on a cosmic scale we don't have a right
to life God can take our lives any time
he wants now those you might say those
are obvious exceptions but they are
exceptions which means that the right to
life is not absolute which means that
maybe it's a it's not the best phrase to
use maybe it's a little confusing so
maybe a better way of putting this would
be that parents have a responsibility to
their children
maybe that's firmer ground to stand on
actually than right-to-life
parents have a responsibility to the job
that's your child you have a
responsibility to the child
and you do not have the authority to
kill innocent human life especially your
child so you know responsibility is a
word I think we could use more often
dignity
now dignity can be also a little bit
abstract and difficult to describe but I
think that's part of what we're reaching
for when we talk about rights and
equality we're reaching for the fact
that you know as people we life has
meaning and value and so you you know
you can't just go killing people and
treating people like like dirt so we use
these words rights and equality it's not
exactly right but we do have dignity so
we have human dignity we have
responsibilities okay now I think we're
on firmer ground we're talking about
something real that most people can
understand okay completely irrelevant to
anything you were saying what were you
talking about you were talking about how
we talk how we have meaningful
discussions okay what's necessary to
have a meaningful discussion I think
they have a meaningful discussion
putting equality to the side I don't
think it's necessary at all I don't
think you have to think of someone as
your equal to have a meaningful dialogue
with them I think meaningful dialogue
means first of all both everyone
involved in the dialogue has to be
interested in having an actual dialogue
which means that they're not saying
their part and then waiting for a turn
to talk again while they tune out
whatever you're saying which is how I
think most people have conversations
whether it's small talk or or meaningful
deep political discussions whatever it
is I think most people when they're
talking to people they're they're really
just talking and the listening part is
them waiting their turn to talk again so
you can't do that and number two I think
everyone involved in the discussion has
to be willing to believe that the other
people in the discussion are operating
in good faith that they that those
people talking believe what they're
saying and and they have reasons to
believe it which isn't to say that all
views are equally valid or whatever
because they're not of course but just
that everyone has a point of view that
is real and that they
arrived at honestly now the problem is
that we know plenty of people
participate in bad faith discussions and
say things that they don't really mean
and if that's the case and you're
talking to someone who's operating in
bad faith then there's no reason to talk
to them at all but if you're gonna
attempt to have a dialogue with someone
on any issue you have to be willing to
believe even if it's maybe not true you
just have to be willing to accept and
and and pretend that this person is
means what they're saying and if you
have those two things if you're you know
you're both operating in good faith and
you see good faith in the other person
and you believe that they have a real
perspective that they've arrived at for
some reason even if it's in your opinion
not a great reason if you forgot that
and you're interested in hearing them
out then I think you can have I think
you can have a discussion you can have a
debate it can go somewhere this by the
way is one of the reasons why a lot of
the discussions between eith atheists
and theists don't go anywhere well one
reason is they're just so far apart on
such a fundamental issue so it's going
to be hard to have a discussion no
matter how you're going about it but the
other problem is that in my experience
from what I've noticed both sides tend
oftentimes to assume that the other side
doesn't really fully believe what
they're saying I hear this from atheists
who
question whether we theists really
believe what we say they just they can't
wrap their heads around it how could you
possibly believe this I was watching
some discussion on maybe YouTube or
debate or something but they'll remember
where it was but there were atheists
we're all basically in agreement that
Catholics who talk about the real
presence in the Eucharist that is that
Jesus is really there in the Eucharist
and a mystical but real way the
agreement among atheists was they don't
really believe that thank you there's no
way they believe that
- then it's crazy that makes no sense so
they say you don't really believe it
then on the other end you've got theists
who very often will say about atheists
you don't you you know that I'm right
you're just not admitting it you know
deep down and all of it so you don't
really believe what you're saying either
well if that's how you're gonna go into
the discussion it's not going to go
anywhere there's no hope you might why
even talk whatever you whatever you're
saying is gonna be tuned out by the
other person it will go nowhere it's
absolutely pointless if you're gonna
even bother to talk to somebody about an
issue like this you have to at least
assume that they really believe what
they're saying even if you don't
understand it and the fact that both
sides assume the other doesn't believe
what they're saying should be
indications to both sides that the other
side does believe what they're saying
they believe it so much that they can't
even believe that anyone could believe
anything else which if anything at with
which if nothing else tells you that
they really believe what they're saying
at least they believe it you know
they're they're they're very they're
firm in their beliefs at the very
minimum okay I did have other emails I
want to answer well this one I I said I
was done with a spanking topic but first
of all you know that when I say I'm done
with the topic it means I'm gonna talk
about it for the next three weeks so
that's one thing but also there was I
got I got myriad emails about one
particular thing I said when we were
talking about the spanking topic of
Friday that apparently I I wasn't clear
on a certain point so I wanted to read
this email and respond to it because I
won't be able to rest until I clarify my
point on this because I do want to be
understood so this is from Matthias as
hi
I know you said you were done with the
spankin topic but I had one last thought
/ objection in an attempt to explain
your position you said that spanking is
they do as I say not as I do thing
because you tell your kids not to hit
and then you'd be hitting but then you
said that timeouts aren't do as I say
not as I do even though your kids can't
put each other in timeout and you said
that if your daughter asks why she can't
put her brothers in timeout you would
say that she doesn't have the authority
so why could that why why couldn't that
be the reason why they don't hit also
the way you talk about hitting ie we
don't hit it makes it sound like you're
saying hitting is never okay but what
about self defense etc I just think your
position is not well thought-out okay so
yes Mathias I said last week the crucial
thing here is what a kid can understand
so there's the issue of sort of
objectively is spanking ethical and
effective in itself which I think it
isn't but we almost don't need to talk
about that because there's also the
issue of what the child can understand
so even if maybe you're right on the
spanking topic academically maybe maybe
you beat me philosophically on the
debate and you can demonstrate that
really actually it is ethical and there
is a real distinction between spanking
and hitting and so on let's just say
that you that's the case it really
doesn't matter if the kid can't
understand this abstract nuanced
philosophical distinction that you've
drawn and and you know I may not be the
smartest bulb
especially when I'm mixing metaphors
like that I may not be the smartest bulb
in there in the cran box but I think if
I can't understand it it was probably an
indication that a three-year-old can't
and punishing a kid in a way that they
cannot possibly understand and that they
lack the cognition to understand is
wrong let me give you a brief example of
an of an objectively ethical punishment
that would be wrong because of the
child's inability to understand and this
is one that I've done before I'm guilty
of back when my oldest son was maybe
three years old we were out in public he
was misbehaving this happened multiple
times actually misbehaving okay act
acting like a like a three-year-old
you know like they tend act but I
couldn't really punish him at the time
because of the situation we were in so
when we got home four or five hours
later I put him in timeout
for the thing he had done earlier in the
day nothing wrong with timeouts I don't
think anyone would argue that there's
something unethical about timeouts at
least I'm not gonna argue that but this
was wrong me punishing my kid in this
context with the timeout was wrong why
because at that age if you're going to
give a child a consequence it has to be
immediate with the way that they
remember time and the way they perceive
time if you punish them for something
that happened hours ago they aren't
going to understand what you're doing
they can't understand it now if it's if
you're talking about 12 year old and
you're punishing them for something they
did earlier in the day or even yesterday
they could understand a three-year-old
can't so if you don't believe me then
then go to a three-year-old ask him what
he did yesterday or even ask him what he
did this morning most likely he'll tell
you some vaguely some some some story
vaguely related to something that
happened a month ago you know or six
months ago or last week because he has
no idea what the word this morning means
or what the word yesterday means or four
hours ago he doesn't know what that
means
so I punish my son but I but but he
didn't understand and I didn't
understand at the time because I I was
still learning how kids operate I didn't
I didn't realize this but he didn't
understand why I was punishing him yeah
he had done this thing but he's not
connecting those dots he can't so for
him you know you put you put a
three-year-old in timeout for something
they did four hours ago in their mind
they're going to associate it with
whatever they most recently did so
if they're if the most recent thing they
did was you know they were sitting on
the couch and now you're putting them a
timeout they're gonna think that you put
them in timeout for sitting on the couch
they're not going to connect the dots
okay so it that's what's wrong because
they don't understand now - spanking and
this is also why by the way this is why
you really don't punish you know we
don't punish infants at all you don't
punish infants for anything no matter
what they're doing because they couldn't
possibly understand the punishment and
so it's nothing would come of it that
would be abuse but an infinite timeout
you know they say timeouts are ethical
but on some cases cases they they might
not be put in put an infant in timeout
that's unethical not a spanking what
matters here or at least one of the
things that really matters is how the
child perceives it and what the child is
going to perceive regardless of whatever
academic argument or nuance distinction
you draw as an adult what they're going
to perceive is daddy is hitting me and
then his child brain is gonna say daddy
says don't hit but daddy is hitting
that's what the child is going to think
you bring up the issue of authority with
putting my kids in timeout my point
there is that when my daughter asked
when my daughter has tried to put her
brothers in timeout and I say no and she
says why the answer I give is because
you're not in mommy only mommy and
daddies put kids in timeout that was the
reason I gave her reason she could
understand there's no point in giving a
reason for something if they can't
understand the reason so it has to be a
very simple reason
what about hitting when my daughter hits
her brother what's the reason I give for
why she shouldn't hit I don't say only
mommy and daddy's hit no you can't hit
cuz you're not the mommy only mommies
and daddy said you're not allowed to hit
only we hit I don't say that no parent
says even parents who spank when you're
telling your kids not to hit what's you
don't give them the reason that they
don't have the authority to hit of
course you don't say that would be crazy
a totally crazy thing to say to a kid
because from a child's perspective
that's gonna be so confusing to be given
that reason
because now they're gonna think weights
okay hitting is okay but so hitting is
okay as long as adults do it and do you
see where that kind of thinking is gonna
lead a kid what what you're opening them
up to is no you're not gonna say that so
what you say when you say don't hit the
reason that every parent gives is we
don't hit it's wrong to hit hitting
hurts we don't hurt people you have to
say that like that because it's what the
kid can understand you're talking to a
three or four-year-old
you're speaking in very short little
sentences that's all they can understand
you bring up self-defense sure but I'm
not getting into the ethics of
self-defense or rules of military
engagement with a toddler so I say we
don't hit yeah I mean there are
exceptions to that obviously but I'm not
getting into the exceptions and at that
age all that matters is the very basic
concept I need them to get that down and
then later on we can get into the
exceptions it's just like I tell my kids
don't steal we don't steal stealing is
bad now I'm not gonna get into
hypotheticals about what if you're
starving and your kids are starving and
you're walking through a cornfield and
it's somebody else's cornfield can you
eat the corn even though technically
you're stealing the corn the answer is
yes you can in fact in that case it
would be ethical to eat the corn it'd be
unethical not to give your kids some
corn because as it turns out do not
steal is not in absolute is not an
ethical absolute there are cases where
stealing is okay so you know in wartime
you send a spy on a mission to go steal
the other the other the other militaries
battle plans or whatever I mean that's
stealing too but that's that's ethical
but I don't get into that with kids i
what I say to them is we don't steal
stealing is bad and it's important that
I don't do anything that seems to
contradict that unless the kids really
are starving in the cornfield so for
them it's a very simple message the anti
hitting message is very simple for a
child it's an important message it's a
message I need them to get down and
either I need to lay the basic framework
of it later on down the road when
they're older I can start filling in
some of the particulars and we can get
in
some of that stuff but we're not at that
point yet they're not old enough for
that and so I just need them to
understand so they can be civilized
gracious you know people at this age I
just need them to understand don't hit
and I don't want to do anything that
might undermine that or might confuse
them about it that's it
so that's the point okay let's see one
other emails is from Katie says Matt
loved the show on Twitter you were
asking people about issues about about
issues about which they change their
minds issues they change their minds
about see that what happens when you try
not to you try to you know try to
sometimes you try to write that
grammatically correct sentence and it
comes off confusing then you listed a
bunch of issues you've flipped on over
the years then you said quoting you I've
increasingly found that ideological
labels are irrelevant to me I've become
much more libertarian I've become both
more libertarian and less over time more
conservative and less these labels are
useless and there's nothing more
uninteresting than a person whose views
align completely with one camp quoting
me that's what I said yes you often
preach about intellectual inconsistency
but here you are talking about the times
you've flip-flopped like it's a good
thing what's wrong with a person
remaining firm in their convictions well
first of all I criticize flip-flopping
when it's done or seems to have been
done usually by a politician in a
cynical and opportunistic way not a
sincere and authentic way so that's bad
flip-flopping usually when we call a
politician a flip-flop or what we're
saying is their opinions change
according to surveys according to the
poll polling data so that's bad
flip-flopping okay but if you really
just change your mind about something
over time I've never criticized anybody
for that because that's that's a good
thing that shows that somebody is
thoughtful and honest and that they're
really trying to figure things out I do
value intellectual consistency but when
I say consistency I don't mean that your
views of today are consistent with your
views of twenty years ago
that kind of consistency is is not
important and is probably a bad sign if
it if anything I mean think about it if
you've never changed your mind about
anything major
that means you basically still maintain
all of the opinions you had when you
were in high school and those weren't
even your opinions those were your
parents opinions that you inherited and
those were the opinions that you
inherited from your family and from your
friends in your community I mean the
opinions you have as a kid are not
really yours fully because you haven't
had time to think about it your mind is
not fully formed yet and if you're if
you're if your values and opinions
haven't changed at all since then I
think that's a sign that you're that
you're not thinking that's why people
people like to give Bernie Sanders
credit because he's been saying the same
stuff for 40 years I don't really give
him credit for that because number one
he's been wrong for 40 years but number
two I don't think you should be saying
the same things that's at 78 that you
were saying you know when you were in
your 30s or 20s or teens I'm not saying
that all of your views and opinions
should change completely but you should
have grown and matured and you should
have added some layers at least in
context on to what you're saying some
texture to it and yeah you probably
should have changed your mind about some
things the fact that Bernie Sanders has
been doing the same stick for 40 years
50 years hasn't changed his mind about
anything tells me he's not a very
thoughtful person he had one he has one
simplistic way of looking at things and
it has and it has not grown there's been
no depth added to it at all I don't
think that's good so I think we should
be constantly refining our positions
rethinking our positions and analyzing
them we should always be asking
ourselves why okay here's what I believe
why do I believe it what is my reason
for believing that such-and-such is true
and we should ask ourself that and and
and I feel like if you do that survey
now where you go through all your
beliefs you say why do I believe these
things but first of all you're gonna
discover that there are a number of
beliefs you hold that aren't really your
beliefs because you have no reason to
believe them that you can think of it's
just something that you've passively
inherited it doesn't mean it's wrong but
it means okay now I got to take a look
at that
and figure out is it right or wrong I
don't know but if you if you if you
conduct that personal survey now and
then you could conduct it again 20 years
from now you're gonna find different
results so when I talk about consistency
I think it's not that we need vertical
consistency in our ideas where we have
the same ideas up and down the Aged up
and down the years we were saying the
same things so that's the sort of
vertical intellectual consistency I
don't think that that is important I
think what's important is horizontal
consistency where all of your current
views are consistent with your other
current views where you have one
consistent where you're you've give your
principles your convictions your ethical
views and you apply them consistently to
all the issues and you don't have any
beliefs currently that contradict each
other that's the kind of consistency and
we all and none of us are 100%
consistence it consistent horizontally
with our beliefs but that's the
consistency I think we want to strive
for and when you try to establish that
kind of consistency when you say okay I
think this about this topic and this
about that topic wait a second they
don't really match up there's a when we
start doing that that's that's part of
the way we discover that we're wrong
about something that's you know that's
one of the ways I that I found I
considered myself to be wrong about I
mean I've been wrong about a lot of
things but for example marijuana
legalization so I'm in favor of it now I
didn't used to be but I conducted a
personal survey and I found that okay I
believe this and that about the
government's role in society and what I
want the government to be doing and yet
I want the government to be spending
billions of dollars trying to stop
people from smoking weed it didn't
really make sense according to my own
personal convictions so I had to change
it I didn't even really want to change
it because honestly you know I don't
it's not my thing and I'm not a big fan
of like pothead so I it's not even it's
not a belief that I really wanted to
hold but I realize that I kind of have
to because otherwise I'm being
hypocritical in my view
so all right well we'll wrap it up there
a lot of interesting emails I do
appreciate appreciate it and talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hay supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer austin stevens editor donovan
fowler audio mixer robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Kleber show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]